what is 5g including sub 6 gigahertz 5g
and millimeter wave 5g how does it work
and
maybe the most important question is how
will it change the world in the coming
years
when we set ourselves to develop 5g and
you know we look at this every
generation of technology had a problem
to be solved right so you mentioned to g
to g challenge the challenge of cdma was
can we give every person on earth a cell
phone that was can you get to a
technology that you can
basically allow everyone to have a
mobile phone
3g was about the ability to connect that
to the internet i think 4g was broadband
and with 4g was about have the ability
for you to have a computer in the palm
of your hand we just talked about that
5g the challenge was a little bit
different
it's how do we build a technology for a
society that is going to be 100
connected to the cloud how do we provide
a technology that is going to be the
last mile connectivity for everything
so 5g has is basically been designed
eliminate all issues with data
congestion whether you are in and uh
stadium we talk about soccer you're in a
stadium and everyone should be ability
to have access to broadband so deal with
congestion
deal with the fact that not only people
but billions of things need to be
connected
create a technology that for the first
time in wireless you could deliver
mission critical services
wireless used to
up to 4g is its best effort in 5g it can
guarantee that you're connected with the
cloud and then the last point
of that
is provide this fabric that will allow
us as a society
to look at things that are not connected
and say that's the exception that's why
we made a comparison in the early days
of 5g that that's going to be like
electricity right now you don't have a
discussion about what's the use cases
for electricity you don't talk about
that anymore you just assume it's there
and that's how we think about everything
connected to the cloud that's what 5g is
and that's the role of 5g
so first of all everything connected to
the cloud is interesting because the
space of everything is constantly
increasing that isn't correct you know i
don't think the refrigerator over there
it looks kind of smart but i don't think
it's connected yet
uh to the cloud so this includes
internet of things
what is the full space of everything
the full space of everything is it's uh
maybe going back to
where you start defining qualcomm
qualcomm is about communications and
advanced computers for low power devices
and can we make everything smart you
know it can range from
the robot you have right now on the
floor
to your refrigerator to to a camera
to
you know machines in manufacturing
to retail etc
i can give you some examples when
when we think of something as simple as
going to
to the grocery shop
we see technology now
with
something that's the stuff we've been
working with companies like walmart
electronic shelf labels the ability for
you to have smart cameras they can look
at shelves and can the camera is smart
enough to say some product needs to be
replenished ability to see with star so
it's about really providing processor
connectivity artificial intelligence
to everything and
i think that's one of the largest uh
addressable markets we have for
technology because you can't really
define everything right exactly it's a
nice market because it keeps growing
potentially exponentially in speed
um
what about coverage so how are we doing
on the everything part so
you know there is like i mentioned sub
six gigahertz 5g and there's a
millimeter wave 5g so not all 5g is made
the same so there's a speed there's a
bandwidth thing
and then there's coverage how many
people get to enjoy
today and how does the progress in the
next 5 10 20 30 50 years you think looks
like in terms of coverage great topic
conversation so let's talk about this
when i meet with regulators
across the globe i i tell them
resistance is futile allocate every
spectrum to wireless every spectrum
needs to be allocated to wireless the
reality is when we start moving from
cdma to
ofdma
we knew that
there's this industry has done a lot to
get more bits per hertz but the reality
is
uh the massive amount of improvements
that is required
in capacity and in speed uh you need
more spectrum you know there's there's
not so much we can rely on more bits per
hertz you just need more spectrum and if
you look
for example what carriers since the 2g
era they participate in different
license and auctions and every spectrum
they accumulated from 2g or 3g or 4g
all of that you may be able to get one
or two channels max of sub 6
which is a channel is about 100
megahertz or 200 megahertz and that's it
so
we we need more spectrum so 5g has been
designed to work across every spectrum
from the low frequency bands that's we
call the sub 6
but you needed more you needed to go to
the millimeter wave so that's why
five 5g is a technology that you can
deploy from 450 megahertz as an example
or 600 or 700 uh all the way to in the
42
gigahertz
and that's where millimeter wave comes
into the picture now
let's now connect this to your question
about coverage uh of 5g
the easiest thing to do uh
is to deploy
5g in the new spectrum you can get uh
which is uh in the sub 6 you see bands
being auctioned across the globe into
3.5 gigahertz
there's nothing special about the band
is this the only one that was available
because everything else being used for
4g
and you can deploy on that go into
existing cell towers and just put a new
equipment without having to build new
towers but when you go to technology
such as millimeter wave
then you have to build more dense
networks you need to build more stations
because the deployment in that case look
like a wi-fi deployment it's almost like
wi-fi access points when you need to
build more stations you need permits you
need to build fiber so it takes more
time to densify so what you see
happening is coverage has been built
fast with subjects uh across the globe
now the united states also have the
sub-six
uh so that gets you to coverage very
fast
but millimeter wave it's moving and uh
if you always say for example verizon
the united states has had a leadership
uh in building millimeter wave it takes
time i'll say cities like
chicago manhattan starting to get
coverage
it will be a process over a number of
years as you build
uh those different access points type
networks but it's inevitable
there's not enough spectrum so every 5g
operators just a matter of time we'll
have millimeter wave as well resistance
is futile okay so uh for millimeter wave
we need density of access points
and
what's the biggest resistance for
qualcomm
for human civilization
is it uh politicians regulators federal
regulators
is it
individual humans
is it not enough money from the consumer
perspective like what who is the biggest
pain in the butt
from a qualcon's standpoint but
answering the question about what it
takes to build all this technology
i i think regulators across the board
understood the importance of 5g i have
not met a regulator that said it's
really important to be late on 5g i
don't think anybody wants to be late on
5g and as a result we've seen enormous
amount of progress in getting spectrum
allocated to 5g i think the real issue
is the time that it takes to build
infrastructure
you know investment in 5g infrastructure
special millimeter wave is like building
roads and ports it's critical
infrastructure and those things take
time like one of the number one obstacle
you're going to hear from operators is
site permit
you know sometimes they have to
negotiate municipality by municipality
about permits to get new cell sites but
you know the networks will be densified
and
and you're going to need all of the
capacity for the promise of the fully
immersive augmented reality that will
replace phones and everything being
connected 100 of the time this would not
be a conversation with the ceo if i did
not ask
questions that make you nervous
some people raise concerns about there
not being enough studies about the
effects of 5g on the human body
is 5g safe
look
i have a very simple answer uh
to to to this question
as
we built
new capabilities such as 5g power is
going down
especially when you think about reducing
the number of base stations the
network's becoming more dense
so
as you do that the the power
becomes lower if you're radiated from
power radiated from the phone and from
the tower as you get closer to the tower
you don't need that much power to reach
the tower so as
as we move from 4g to 5g i think we see
a reduction in the amount of powers
required to close the radio link now
also you have a number of organizations
the fcc for example has rigorous uh
programs which they do a lot of tests
to validate uh you know the safety of
those devices and i think we have
has been a model for other countries
also to adopt the same things uh
cellular has been around for a number of
decades now uh i think smartphone is our
most beloved device uh today
and i i would argue
how it's difficult to answer those
questions because you
yeah but i'll argue that the data to
date have we seen in 3g and 4g
um
you know has uh shown that uh
a lot of the initial concerns were not
valid
we look at 5g even though it's new it's
just less power so we're looking from
from a physics standpoint so from a
physics from a biology perspective
there's a lot of evidence there's
studies
that show that it's not uh dangerous
that it is in fact safe however the
concern that people have is when you
scale technology exponentially
um
how would that change human civilization
i mean that doesn't apply to 5g that
applies to every technology how you said
smartphone is the most beloved device
but love
sometimes hurts
that's
an impact on society we don't know and
and there's a little bit of fear there's
both excitement and fear
it's a great topic a conversation
actually so so let me give you my
perspective on this and you started to
see something's exactly happening right
now so let me step back
and let's talk about the fact that we
are in a fully interconnected society
that when
when uh when you look of the situation
today we talk about smartphones uh
largest uh development platform uh so
much now of our life uh
we are connected to the smartphone and
as a result and we are all connected and
we're connected and then we're building
digital twins of everything right so so
when you look at that picture when you
look at the picture of this connected
society
you started to have
the following thoughts which i think are
very healthy which means in the same way
that in the physical world
you're entitled to some rights you have
obligations and there's a lot of uh
things that protect your your integrity
i think as a rule we're going to see the
society evolving so those things extend
to your digital being
of people and things and i think just
natural it's just natural uh it's just a
natural path and you started to see
things like that for example the
europeans has done
a lot in this area i'll say the
europeans probably ahead in the united
states and thinking about privacy laws
digital privacies law most recent the
dma the digital markets act which i
think is a great thing i think we're
we believe there's incredible uh thought
in to enable ability to regulate the
digital market so that there's
innovation and competitions and not not
a single company uh can control all the
data and then decide you know uh
how things are gonna be work on the
digital realm and even if we think about
the potential things like the meta
versus we're connecting physical and
digital spaces so i think it's a natural
evolution of course regulate regulation
and laws always follow technology but
but the fact that we're uh moving to our
interconnected society there's there's
no going back uh we are a fully
interconnected society but there is
opportunity uh to think about how the
digital twin uh
should peop people and government should
think about it so that we get the best
of a technology we doubt that any
downside yeah so when you say digital
twin that's one of the other things
you're excited about which is the
metaverse are basically building worlds
in the in the digital space and you have
to start to think about all the basic
human rights
that transfer from our physical meat
vehicles out to the digital copies of
ourselves representations of ourselves
it's really important to think about the
thing you mentioned about regulators
that has been this is me speaking
frustrating is like you said
they follow technology so sometimes they
don't get the technology at all
so they're very clumsy in writing laws
that
censor that technology in interesting
ways they mean good but they can do a
lot of unintended damage now
both it's a dance it's a beautiful dance
but i just wish governments were better
dance partners i just see what they're
kind of writing now about regulating
social media and
platforms like youtube and it's just
really really clumsy they don't
understand how machine learning works
how recommender systems work and i just
wish they kind of caught up a little
more because it's really important to be
great
at regulation
but also it's important to let companies
flourish and embrace this new wave of
technology that that weird dance i i'm
more and more learning looking at public
public policy how much positive
government can do and how much clumsy
negative it can do unintentionally just
out of sheer incompetence or lack of
curiosity about tech
that's my rant about regulators
i think it's a valid point
as i said before thank the europeans
probably have a very good framework but
you know the way the way i'll oh think
about it we we depend on have the
ability to innovate we depend on the
free markets we depend
on the ability to create uh you know
technology that uh that would be
disruptive
but at the same time i think the tech
companies probably should spend time
helping governments understand helping
understand ahead of time so that they
can be better prepared
you